[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren kommen sie war ein bisschen mehr
ich habe jemanden mitgebracht ein süßer
kleiner roboter namens cosmo wir sehen
hier was der kann der kann nämlich diese
kisten aufeinander stapeln und sie
danach wieder umwerfen
und das ist natürlich nur eine spielerei
und erst der anfang
künstliche intelligenz durch trinkt mehr
und mehr unser gesamtes leben die frage
ist was kommt da eigentlich auf und zu
und vor welchen gefahren ist mir uns
jetzt schon schützen
darüber spreche ich mit dem bekannten
wissenschaftsjournalisten und moderator
ranga yogeshwar hat ja dieses ding ja
ist das intelligent nein das ist nicht
intelligent aber heute ist es so dass
ganz gerne auf ganz viele verschiedene
produkte intelligent darauf geschrieben
wird also auf der markt waschmaschine
stets auch drauf das sind ein paar
sensoren und mehr nicht aber das
spannende ist wenn man kleine kinder
fragt ist das intelligent sagen sie in
bestimmten altersstufen durchaus ja man
hat das genauer untersucht und stefanie
kruger hat dazu eine spannende
untersuchung gemacht und festgestellt am
anfang haben kinder das gefühl ja das
sei intelligent wenn sie in die schule
gehen ist es sogar noch größer weil
diese maschinen auf zu viele dinge
scheinbar wissen aber in dem moment wo
man anfängt diese maschine zu
programmieren zu gestalten dann ändert
sich das also je besser man diese
technik versteht umso mehr merkt man
nicht
aber ich weiß das ist nur eine spielerei
sehr hübsch gemacht muss man sagen aber
sie sagen künstliche intelligenz das
wird unser leben unsere gesellschaft
grundlegend verändern in den nächsten
jahren und jahrzehnten was kommt da auf
uns zu da ganz viel ganz viele
verschiedene dinge also fangen wir mal
einfach bei solchen intelligenten
spielzeugen an wir erleben heute eine
generation die ein kids die nicht nur
wie die davor mit internet aufgewachsen
sind sondern plötzlich mit intelligenten
spiels heute aufwachsen mit
sprachassistenten mit denen sie sprechen
können und das ändert natürlich sehr
viel
schon alleine im umgang wenn wir aber
künstliche intelligenz in der breite
betrachten ist glaube ich das was sie
auszeichnet dass ganz viele verschiedene
lebensbereiche von den medien über die
art wie wir dinge fertigen bis hin zur
medizin oder dem miteinander von
menschen immer mehr geprägt wird durch
das was man künstliche intelligenz nennt
also insofern passiert und wird dann
noch viel mehr passieren
und über diese gesellschaftlichen folgen
werden wir ja ich noch sprechen sie
beschäftigen sich seit jahren intensiv
mit der digitalisierung mit künstlicher
intelligenz haben kürzlich einen
dokumentarfilm gedreht und sind um die
haube oder die ganze welt gerade im
silicon valley in kalifornien über
england bis nach china
wer führten derzeit die forschung an das
rennen um die künstliche intelligenz
also wenn die frage ist erschwert das
rennen an und wir nur auf ökonomische
zahn gucken dann sind sicherlich die usa
und china führen wenn die frage lautet
wer für die forschung an ist die antwort
schon ein bisschen anders denn wenn man
wirklich genau hinschaut wo geforscht
wird welche menschen da sitzen dann gibt
es zum beispiel hier in zürich an der
eth großartige wissenschaftler die
wirklich sehr sehr gut sind so gut sind
dass google zum beispiel sich hier
ansiedelt und anfängt
das know how von der eth zum beispiel
abzusaugen
es gibt in deutschland große hat der
heute in großbritannien also das ist er
verteilt aber was sie eben erleben ist
die guten ideen sprießen die theorien
sprießen an verschiedenen stellen aber
die umsetzung erfolgt hauptsächlich in
den usa und in china und japan gilt der
achse aus einem nahen japan ist ein land
was natürlich gerade was robotics
betrifft sehr viel macht aber das ist
zumindest mein eindruck dass künstliche
intelligenz im detail also wenn man über
machine learning nachdenkt oder wenn man
neuronale netze nimmt also in all den
bereichen ist japan nicht ganz so
führend wieder reste machine learning
maschinelles lernen und neuronaler netze
darüber sprechen wir gleich noch jetzt
in der recherche habe ich bin ich war
ich verblüfft was ki heute eigentlich
schon kann und wir schauen uns dazu 23
ganz kleine beispiel ja
millionen kameras im öffentlichen raum
verknüpft mit künstlicher intelligenz
zur gesichtserkennung
so überwacht china seine bevölkerung
kampf roboter & autonome waffensysteme
ausgerüstet mit ki identifizieren
verfolgen und attackieren ziele
selbstständig humanoide roboter
interagieren mit menschen und zeigen
regungen und gefühle selbstfahrende
autos sind genauso mit kali ausgerüstet
wie autonome landwirtschaftliche
maschinen amazon wusste dank künstlicher
intelligenz bereits vor den kunden was
diese für weihnachten bestellen werden
und füllte entsprechend die lager
neueste übersetzungs geräte dolmetschen
über 30 sprachen
ja schon vergriffen worüber starten sie
persönlich denn am heißt das letzte
beispiel ist sehr schön also die
übersetzung wir haben zum beispiel in
china geht und in shenzen
das ist so bei kamerateams die müssen
ein canet ausfüllen also wenn sie das
kamera equipment in ein land bringen
müssen sich danach wieder ausführen
sonst wäre das ein import im dafür
braucht man ein zettel und wir haben uns
genauso mit den zollbeamten in shenzen
unterhalten also es ging nur über den
apparat die sprache mandarin wir
englisch und es ging hin und her also
das zeigt im grunde genommen schon ein
bisschen brüchig was damit möglich ist
und wenn man zum beispiel in dem kontext
mal weiter denkt kann man sich klar
machen was das eigentlich zum beispiel
für ein heterogenes gebilde wie die
europäische union gedeutet im moment ist
es so dass die eu nicht eine gemeinsame
sprache hat und das ist manchmal komplex
wenn man nach brüssel geht oder
straßburg sieht man die vielen vielen
übersetzer kapiert für die schweizer
auch in kleinen vielleicht den kleinen
aber er sei zumindest eine nation
aber wenn man einfach mal ein paar jahre
in die zukunft denkt wird es so sein
dass jeder europäer sich flüssig mit dem
anderen unterhalten kann weil dank
übersetzungsprogramm dank apparaten wir
live sozusagen diesen dialog führen
können in unterschiedlichen sprachen
kann sich vielleicht denken dass ich
irgendwann mit einem knopf im ohr und
einer brille durch irgendwie peking
laufe und mir wird alles übersetzen
ich verstehe die leute und so weiter
dank künstlicher also es gibt heute
schon im herbst reality nennt man das
also man hat schon die möglichkeit mit
dem smartphone zum beispiel texte mit
der kamera zu erfassen und die werden
dann automatisch übersetzt also insofern
das ist alles da aber das ist wir nennen
das künstliche intelligenz wenn man
genauer hinschaut ist das nicht
sonderlich intelligent
ich nenne das korrelation maschinen also
was passiert ist
das hier im grunde genommen systeme
gefüttert werden mit ganz vielen
verschiedenen texten mit übersetzungen
diese systeme in anführungszeichen
lernen das heißt sie schaffen wenn man
so will statistischer bezüge und auf die
art und weise können sie dann im
nächsten schritt zum beispiel beim text
anfangen zu übersetzen
aber was man sich klar machen muss ist
der intelligenteste text übersetzte
maschinell gesehen versteht nichts also
er begreift nicht was die wörter heißen
ersetzt im grunde genommen nur hohl
zusammen aber das wird natürlich auf uns
zu als würde erst verstehen aber müssen
sie immer klar machen der ist nicht so
intelligent wie wir denken
man merkt schon herr yogeshwar sie
können komplexe sachverhalte sehr
einfach verständlich und unterhaltsam
vermitteln und präsentieren und sie
wurden auch vielfach preisgekrönt als er
derart unterschiedliche sendungen
gemacht wissen vor 8 die große
wissensshow der naturwunder und quarks &
co dafür sind sie wahrscheinlich am
bekanntesten 25 jahre glaube ich haben
sie das material zu unterschiedlichsten
themen und für diejenigen zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer unter ihnen die die
sendung nicht kennen schauen wir mal
rein die wdr sendung kölner treff hat
ein paar höhepunkte zusammengestellt
hallo herzlich willkommen bei quad
herzlich willkommen bei crocs herzlich
willkommen bei quarks & co
[Musik]
das ist ein wort reisen wir mal zum
maßnehmen physikalisch sozusagen ein
ding der unmöglichkeit die reise durch
den winter im schnitt etwa 78 millionen
kilometer theorie
tja schön
wann wurde ihnen denn klar dass das ihr
talent ist oder ihre begabung hat sie
dass das tier wieder seien mit der
ermittlung von rissen eine breite
öffentliche also diese sendungen habe
ich alle gebaut also moderator das ist
manchmal der fall wenn leute irgendwo in
ein gemachtes bett gesetzt werden in
meinem fall war so dass ich diese betten
immer selber baute das war der spaß es
war ursprünglich auch nicht so dass ich
vor die kamera wollte also was mich
interessiert ist inhalt und im grunde
genommen gab es so einige ereignisse
waren zurückgibt 1986 tschernobyl und
das war so das erste mal dass ich mir du
weniger vor eine kamera gezerrt wurde
weil es anfangs okay niemand weiß wie
man das erklären kann juwi ist physiker
du hast da gearbeitet bitte macht und
das war am anfang ehrlich gesagt nicht
so unbedingt das was ich wollte
aber so mit der zeit hat sich das
geändert es ist für mich schöner einen
menschen anzugucken als irgendeine
kameralinse aber mit der zeit gewöhnt
man sich dann aber mein anliegen ist
eigentlich gar nicht so sehr
präsenz in so einem medium sondern
inhalt also aber der antrieb ist schon
dass der inhalt an die menschen kommt
man der breite ja und ich glaube was
sich die es ist wir haben themen die
gerade heute wo die medien immer mehr
ich nenne das richtung erregungs
bewirtschaftung gehen das heißt medien
selber fangen nicht nur nicht mehr an zu
sagen das ist wichtig das ist ein thema
darüber müssen wir reden sondern es wird
immer mehr geguckt ja was sind themen
die besonders viel geguckt angeklickt
und sonstwie werden und in der
entsprechung ist es dann so dass das
programm genauso aussieht wie wir es
heute kennen das heißt es dünnt sich
inhaltlich aus ich glaube aber dass es
total wichtig ist über bestimmte themen
zu reden auch wenn sie schwierig sind
unser thema können sie intelligenz ist
ein paradebeispiel dafür
denn es gibt wäre vorstellungen jahr von
robotern von
ausweislich cyborgs oder ähnlichem aber
was bei so einer breiten veränderungen
in der gesellschaft wichtig ist zu
begreifen was kann können sie
intelligenz was kann sie nicht und im
ergebnis was macht sie mit uns mit dem
einzelnen ich nehme wenn ich darf ein
beispiel wenn wir uns heute anschauen
wie die medien sich zum beispiel
verändert haben ich meine hier hat man
gerade einen überblick gehabt über er
fast 30 jahre fernsehen ja das konnte
man an meinem alterungsprozess
nachvollziehen
die medien haben sich phänomenal
geändert durch die digitalisierung durch
soziale netzwerke und durch künstler
intelligenz warum was heute passiert
wenn menschen zb etwas schreiben in
sozialen netzwerken ist dass diese
informationen nicht so ohne weiteres
jedem anderen mitgegeben werden sondern
dass aufgrund des profils des einzelnen
nutzers
und das ist schon mal wichtig wenn wir
selber irgendwo recherchieren im netz
dann werden unsere daten ausgelesen also
wir lesen nicht das netz aus das netz
liest uns aus profiliert uns und in
abhängigkeit des profils bekommen wir
dann informationen also wie ich hacker
lassen eine datenspur wenn das im netz
bewegen und die angebote ob das werbung
ist um das information ist vielleicht
auch politische dann wird es gefährlich
der wird auf uns aus person
zugeschnitten und jeder kriegt was
anderes genau
und das bedeutet dass wir zum einen ein
prozess haben bei denen wir anfangen aus
einer gemeinschaft ein sammelsurium von
individuellen personen zu sehen
und das zweite ist dass die motive
dieser kommunikation ökonomische sind
und das ganz essenziell zu verstehen das
heißt facebook oder google oder twitter
arbeiten an ein business modellen dieses
business modell heißt halte die nutzung
möglichst hoch denn das passieren zwei
dinge das erste ist ich kann die
möglichst bewerbung zeigen
und mache geld damit und das zweite ist
wenn du lange bei mir bist kann ich auch
sehr viele daten zusätzlich gewinnen und
kann damit zb antizipieren wo deine
wünsche sind was deine
kaufentscheidungen für morgen und
übermorgen sind und das aus steckt in
diesen dingen hier drin wären wir
facebook sind werden wir whatsapp sind
wenn wir etwas googeln usw und in der
vorbereitung habe ich wirklich gespannt
was dieses ding eigentlich alles schon
kann wir gucken mal ganz kurz sein
wann ist mein nächster termin gehen
hilft es termin im kalender ist heute um
13 uhr
er heißt kontext bjb sie leitet ein team
das eine neue version von
sprachassistenten entwickelt von
software die gerade bei den hightech
firmen groß im trend liegt dank der
fortschritte bei der sprach und
bilderkennung beantwortet der assistent
alle fragen er soll in allen möglichen
bereichen unschlagbar sein
wer hat ausgemalt wurde da vinci
geschaffen
übersetzt dass das hier könnte stimmen
checken sie werden in bild wie viele
kalorien enthält dass ein apfel enthält
durchschnittlich 95 kalorien
der assistent nistet sich in form eines
intelligenten lautsprechers im trauten
heim 1
je häufiger sie den assistenten
verwenden desto besser wird er
er lernt aus der interaktion ist sich
meinen bedürfnissen an die kann ihm aber
auch dinge beibringen
so kann ich einfach sagen okay meine
lieblingsmannschaft des barcelona ok ich
speichere ab ihre lieblingsmannschaft
ist barcelona ab jetzt erinnert sich der
assistent und ich brauche nur noch zu
sagen meine mannschaft oder wann spielt
meine mannschaft wir müssen nicht lernen
wie man mit einer maschine spricht wir
können einfach reden
sie sagen dem assistenten per google
bestellen mir ein taxi
damit wird er wirklich für alle
zugänglich google wie ist der verkehr
auf dem heimweg der verkehr für die
heimfahrt ist flüssig 28 minuten im auto
erinnere mich zu hause daran mama
anzurufen
natürlich ich erinnere sie daran wenn
sie heimkommen
wenn diese technologie wirklich auf
menschlicher ebene funktioniert ebenso
wie menschen zusammen reden dann ist sie
für jedermann zugänglich ja und ähnliche
systeme gibt es ja nicht nur von google
von sondern ein von apple oder man aber
sagen solche sprachassistenten oder
smarte speakers und wir haben einen hier
nämlich alexa von amazon und mit dieser
alexa kann man einfach sprechen und die
befehle geben fragen stellen das sagen
wir mal kurz testen
doch gerade zu jagen was wir gerade
gesehen haben diesen wissenschaftler
habe ich mal besucht dass der forscher
in zürich und mein sohn war dabei und
hier in zürich ist google maps ist so
einer der der highlights das
interessante ist er hat dann vorgeführt
dass bei google maps inzwischen
sprachassistenten da sind dass man also
auch wirklich reden kann auch mit google
maps das war vor einigen jahren
und dann sagte mein sohn ich finde das
nicht gut ich war total erstaunt ich
sagte warum er sagte was du wenn ich
jetzt in eine fremde stadt
dann ist es so dass ich menschen fragen
kann wo ist der weg ja wie geht das weiß
ich zum zudem hat oder wo auch immer
und ich komme damit in kontakt mit den
menschen
dadurch dass irgendwann ein apparat das
übernimmt wird in ein paar jahren ein
mensch sagen was macht der mich ja an
da guckt doch auf dein smartphone das
heißt diese apparate obwohl die wie
gesagt noch nicht so richtig intelligent
sind führen dazu dass wir plötzlich
anfangen ein verhalten zu ändern und
dieses kommunikative verhalten ist ein
echtes problem das zweite ist dass diese
apparate nicht da sind zum wohle der
menschheit also die dessen ratti
verkaufe von diesen großen it-firmen ist
immer das ist dein persönlicher
assistent aber dass bullshit
er hofft er dann macht das leben
bequemer genau da also das erste ist
dahinter steckt natürlich zuerst einmal
ein ökonomisches ziel also alexa zum
beispiel dient hauptsächlich dazu um den
menschen irgendwann dabei behilflich
sein
zu sachen hinein zu kaufen behilflich
ist schon schön genug ja das heißt es
ist im rennen um ein verkäufer den wir
uns ins haus nehmen ja also stellen sie
sich vor sie wohnen in ihrer wohnung und
jetzt zieht da noch einer an dass der
erste punkte zweiter punkt ist diese
apparate wenn man einfach mal guckt wo
geht es in den nächsten jahren hin
werden natürlich nicht nur sprache
aufzeichnen sie werden anfangen
geräusche zu untersuchen
es gibt sehr erhellende patentanmeldung
wie gesagt das ist noch nicht umgesetzt
aber daran kann man ablesen über was
firmen nachdenken google hat zum
beispiel eine patentanmeldung september
und da wird sehr genau beschrieben wie
man zum beispiel anhand von geräuschen
evaluieren kann ob die kinder sich und
wie lange die kinder sich die zähne
putzen oder ob man anhand des
geräuschpegels feststellt ob zum
beispiel eine person alzheimer hat
das heißt also das heißt diese geräte
hören uns permanent zu argument sich
aktiviert im moment wir können das nie
so richtig prüfen im moment ist es so
dass es ein keyword gibt also entweder
hey google oder alexa und dann wird
eingeschaltet
aber das ist vielleicht nur die erste
stufe und irgendwann öffnet sich das
ganze und spätestens dann muss man sich
mal klar machen was wir eigentlich tun
wir lassen in unserer privatsphäre zu
dass mikrofone installiert wenn also
jemanden ich wohne in deutschland ja
wenn ich in berlin bin und ich mache den
menschen klar da gab es sozusagen noch
zu der ddr zeit ja die stasi die
versucht hat wohnungen zu verwanzen wenn
man der damals gesagt hätte warte
einfach mal die menschen machen das
freiwillig 30er jahren freiwillig
mikrofone mit denen das intimste
abgehört wird hätte man mich für
verrückt erklärt aber dass genau das was
wir heute tun und ich bin da immer sehr
skeptisch weil das narrativ der großen
firmen immer sehr nett ist ja aber wenn
man genauer hinschaut muss man wirklich
sagen was kann man alles damit machen
und es ist atemberaubend zu sehen wie
weit es geht also man kann heute zum
beispiel durch das auswerten von
akustischen signalen wenn menschen
schlafen und sie haben das mobiltelefon
neben sich kann man zum beispiel durch
das schnarchen und so weiter abnehme
patienten rzb isolieren oder gucken wie
ist überhaupt der schlafrhythmus etc
das heißt wir verraten immer mehr daten
das geht bis zum extrem selbst wenn man
alexa nicht hat wenn man ein smartphone
hat diese smartphone wir haben gerade
vorhin darüber gesprochen hat unendlich
viele verschiedene sensoren zb
beschleunigungssensoren und ich war
gerade in birmingham an der ersten
drittel und dessen mathematiker der
tatsächlich dem ist es gelungen dieser
beschleunigungssensor im smartphone
registriert zum beispiel auch wenn wir
gehen also man kann das signal sehr
genau mathematisch an
wie sie an und man kann leichte
abweichungen darin per algorithmus
feststellen und sie können darüber zum
beispiel herausfinden ob eine person
dabei ist gerade packen sind zu bekommen
jetzt müssen sich moment lang fragen
erstens mal was heißt das es ist
großartig was vielleicht eine bessere
diagnostik betrifft aber wollen sie dass
ein telekommunikationshersteller oder
ein mobilfunk hersteller in zukunft weiß
ob sie oder vielleicht ihre frau oder
ihre mutter an parkinson erkrankt und
das zeigt dem boden genommen
exemplarisch die großartigen seiten aber
eben auch die fragen die wir tatsächlich
wirklich diskutieren müssen und zwar
gesellschaftlich ich möchte mit ihnen
gleich noch darüber sprechen aber
erstmal staune ich eigentlich was diese
geräte aus können und damit verbunden
ist immer diese schattenseite der
überwachung da sind wir zu gläsernen
größer werden und das irgendwie diese
künstliche intelligenz nur funktioniert
wenn wir auch so viele daten preise
geben sonst ist er nichts über uns und
ich möchte jetzt trotzdem noch kurz
diese alexa härtesten und stelle jetzt
zwei fragen dann können wir noch mal ein
bisschen weiter das okay alexa wer ist
die ranga yogeshwar wackernagel greco
ihre jüdisch war meist kurz ranga
yogeshwar ist ein luxemburgischer
wissenschaftsjournalist physiker und
moderator
bis jetzt klappt es ja partout wikipedia
zuge kräften ja klar
wir testen auch zwei andere sachen alexa
brauche ich einen schirm morgen
wahrscheinlich wird es morgen in
oerlikon nicht regnen
es besteht nur eine 25 prozentige
wahrscheinlichkeit alexa spiele einen
song von den beatles songs von den
beatles werden von spotify abgespielt
es geht sich auch spotify greift eben
alexa stopp schon erstaunlich erstmal
was da ja das ist erstaunlich aber das
ist auch sehr eng also man muss sich
einfach klarmachen was sie in den
letzten jahren passiert ist ist dass man
im grunde genommen über tut das jetzt
vielleicht hoffentlich nicht hochnäsig
aus aber durch relativ einfache
verfahren also machine learning
neuronalen netze das ist die mathematik
dahinter ist gar nicht so kompliziert
aber aufgrund der tatsache dass wir
computer haben die sehr schnell sind hat
man angefangen im grunde genommen muster
zuzuordnen was heißt das also man kann
muster das kann das digitale bild seien
ja also jedes bild besteht aus
bildpunkten auszahlen und diese zahlen
kann nicht zuordnen und irgendwann habe
ich ein scheinbar intelligentes system
wenn es ein foto macht sagt dass das ist
oder das ist ein auto oder das ist ein
lautsprecher bzw alexa diese zuordnung
funktioniert sehr gut und darf ich kurz
fragen wie das lernen also mit ganz
vielen bildern sollen hier oder von anja
lautsprecher und dann irgendwann lernen
sie wie ein kind vielleicht das ist eine
katze das ist ein hohn die ja der der
unterschied ist dass diese künstlichen
systeme unglaublich viele daten brauchen
das heißt dann mit sie wirklich halbwegs
zuverlässig zum beispiel bilder erkennen
brauchen sie 1100 tausende von bildern
und diese bilder heißt man muss jemand
bild zeigen und sagen das ist dass das
ist ein auto das ist ein glas das ist ja
ein gefäß und das muss man bei jedem
bild machen und dass das system
eigentlich lernt ist so nach und nach zu
korrelieren also sozusagen ein objekt
was so aussieht muss ein glas sein ein
objekt was so aussieht ist eine karaffe
ein objekt was so aussieht muss ein
mensch sein wenn man dann fragt warum
weißt du das dann heißt es nicht war das
system den menschen versteht es ist zum
beispiel sehr spannend man hat versucht
herauszufinden was waren die kategorien
bei einem menschen und was man
feststellt ist falten im stoff der
computer wenn man einen menschen erkenne
er guckt da falten ja also wie falten
machen oder sind ein merkmal was in
kombination mit anderen merkmalen dazu
führt dass die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
es jungen menschen und nicht um eine
teetasse handelt besonders hoch ist
und das zeigt zwei sachen das erste ist
das verständnis davon wie das intern
wirklich funktioniert weil es so viele
daten sind weil es auch so viele
parameter sind die im grunde genommen
verdreht werden müssen damit ein
ergebnis zustande kommt ist bis heute
ein großes problem
man kann ist nicht kausal erklären und
das ist eine große forderung wenn man
sagt ja wenn wir die dinge einsetzen
wollen in der richtigen welt brauchen
wir kausalität sonst landen wir banditen
orakel ja dann landen wir da wo der
algorithmus plötzlich sagte ist schuldig
und der nicht und auf die frage warum
gibt es nur die antwort ja weil der
algorithmus das sagt dann werden jobs
vergeben kredite vielleicht vergeben
aufgrund von kriterien dar wenig kennen
weil die hass denkt eine blackbox so ist
ist wir können nicht verdecken
der zweite punkt ist diese systeme
funktionieren ganz gut wenn man ihnen
daten zeigt und sozusagen bei diesen
daten bleibt es gibt wunderbare
beispiele wo man merkt wie es schief
geht also bilderkennung google hatte mal
ein problem
die haben natürlich viele daten
eingesammelt und nach und nach was man
konnte bilder sehen und dann war immer
drauf das ist ein mensch dass ein auto
das ist ein flugzeug und bei schwarzen
menschen stand plötzlich da gorilla
nicht weil google rassistisch ist das
sind sie wirklich nicht aber weil die
lern daten offensichtlich mehr weiße
menschen beinhaltet haben und plötzlich
eine situation da war rossis kenne ich
nicht was ist am wahrscheinlichsten und
nach den kriterien der maschine war es
dann ein menschenaffe google reagierte
und zog zumindest für eine gewisse zeit
lang dann alle menschenaffen raus weil
es riesenproteste gegeben hätte aber was
das bedeutet ist diese daten beinhalten
vorurteile
diese daten sind möglicherweise nur ein
teil abbild von der realität
und diese systeme erkennen etwas aber
nur in den gesetzten rahmen und das ist
der riesen unterschied zu uns menschen
wir menschen sind in der lage in
komplett neue situation zu gehen und
dinge zu erkennen zusammenhänge zu
erkennen dinge vielleicht sogar kreativ
auszuprobieren das schafft der maschine
nicht
wir lassen uns momentan blenden von
einer mechanik dem grunde genommen
einfach nur muster zuordnet das passiert
bildern das passiert bei den ton wellen
sprich text ja das passiert bei
übersetzungen dadurch dass ich die ein
wörter mit den anderen verkoppelt und
damit sind wir schon fast am ende von
dem was ihr könnt sie intelligenz nennen
also was vielmehr kann sie kann es ist
eine sehr eingeschränkte den kammlagen
künstlicher intelligenz sehr spezifisch
aber nicht dass dieses generelle also
wir können schach spielen aber auch ein
schachbrett aufbauen und so weiter
wir können miteinander reden wir können
ganz verschiedene dinge und die
künstlichen systeme wenn ich sie richtig
verstehen können oft nur eines oder zwei
dinge aber dafür sehr gut vielleicht
auch übermenschliche ja dass das können
sie sicherlich sogar über menschliches
gibt tests wo man zum beispiel
bilderkennung vergleicht mensch maschine
und merkt die maschine wird allmählich
bei einigen bildern besser
das ist natürlich ein großer vorteil in
einigen bereichen man denke an
röntgenaufnahmen wo es darum geht ein
tumor zu identifizieren ja da ist die
maschine inzwischen in einigen bereichen
sogar besser als der mensch aber der
entscheidende punkt ist wenn sozusagen
ein mensch mit einem lungentumor kommt
in der stadt nicht aus der schweiz
sondern was weiß ich aus papua neu
guinea und da sehen vielleicht menschen
zu sagen physisch ein bisschen anders
aus dann scheitern diese systeme und wir
müssen uns also bewusst werden dass das
sehr eng ist
aber nichtsdestotrotz er hat es
natürlich jetzt schon einen enormen
impact weil zb bilderkennung etwas ist
was in der regel ziemlich gut
funktioniert weil die erkennung was weiß
ich das auto schild ist sehr gut
funktionierten diese technologie
inzwischen so günstig geworden ist dass
man jede kleine überwachungskamera damit
ausstatten
und das bedeutet über nacht ist es
plötzlich möglich verkehrsflüsse
tatsächlich sehr genau zu identifizieren
zu wissen okay wo ist die heute morgen
lang gefahren ja wo ist er bilderkennung
zu machen in einer form die eigentlich
unglaublich ist nämlich tatsächlich mit
einer hohen wahrscheinlichkeit menschen
zu verfolgen und das ist natürlich ein
nährboden für länder die vielleicht
nicht demokratisch und das andere
probleme über das möchte ich noch mit
ihnen sprechen nämlich dieses moralische
problem was wenn diese algorithmen
entscheidung treffen oder empfehlungen
geben die irgendwie moralisch nicht okay
sind sie haben das beispiel erwähnt mit
dem dunkelhäutigen mann und das spitzt
sich natürlich zu bei den
selbstfahrenden autos
da gibt es ja nicht weit diskutieren
dieses problem was macht man in
notfällen wo dass es der der wagen nicht
mehr bremsen kann und er steuert auf
fünf personen zu er kann nur umlenken
auf der anderen seite steht eine person
soll jetzt das machen 5 gegen eins auf
diesem moralischen gelernt
die frage ist doch wie sorgen die als
gesellschaft damit umgeht also wie viel
moral müssen wir diesen systemen
einprogrammieren und wenn ja welche ich
fange zuerst einmal daran dass diese
maschinen überhaupt diese tür aufmachen
also wenn wir menschen auto fahren und
einen unfall haben geht es so schnell
dass hier überhaupt keine zeit haben wir
reagieren irgendwelche vielleicht
zufällig oder instinktiv aber nicht
reflektiert dadurch dass diese computer
so schnell sind die sensoren sehr
schnell sind wird wenn man so will die
zeit gestreckt und heute sind sie in der
lage eine situation die für sie als
mensch blitzschnell passiert tatsächlich
im computer zu simulieren und optionen
zu prüfen
das ist zuerst einmal eine neue qualität
das heißt die maschine öffnet ein
fenster zu einer neuen fragestellung die
wir bis dafür massiven können
entscheidungen treffen jetzt und wir
müssen sie jetzt schon treffen sozusagen
antizipieren diese situation oder ja was
was nun passiert ist zuerst einmal
dadurch dass man prinzipiell entscheiden
könnte ja also ich habe
versionen ich habe hier ein fußgänger da
ein fußgänger altmann junge frau hier
kommt das auto und ich habe sozusagen
als wenn es unausweichlich ist eine
dilemma situation wird ein der beiden
treffen
aber ich habe als mensch keine chance
darüber nachzudenken dass wir zufällig
seien aber die maschine kann das jetzt
das zuerst einmal der erste punkt um
jetzt kommen fragen auf also wer so zu
sagen fällt die entscheidung ja der
programmierer wird sagen naja was soll
ich jetzt programmieren ja links oder
rechts und covern vom hat etwas
entwickelt das mantel maschinen also ist
hingegangen hat gesagt okay ich mache
dieses experiment ich nehme ganz viele
menschen und gebe denen vor stelle dir
vor du würdest in einem autonomen
fahrzeug sitzen wie sollte das autonome
fahrzeug seines erachtens entscheiden
und hat dann situationen gehabt wie die
hier also älterer mensch junges kind wer
soll leben wer soll sterben und das hat
er gemacht mit 40 millionen solcher
daten hat er gesammelt und jetzt merkt
man zwei sachen das erste ist es gibt so
ein paar konsens weltweit
kinder sollen verschont werden die zahl
der menschen ja spielt irgendwie eine
rolle
aber wenn man dann in die verschiedenen
kulturen rheinblick merkt man es gibt
große unterschiede
das heißt wir haben es hier nicht mit
einer global gültigen moral oder mit
wertesystem zu tun sondern je nach land
je nach kultur raum ist das
unterschiedlich in bestimmten ländern in
asien zb ist der status einer person
wichtiger als in anderen ländern
in manchen ländern ist die frauen nicht
so wichtig wie der mann ja es gibt sogar
kleine unterschiede zwischen deutschland
und frankreich in frankreich ist es so
dass franzosen er die frau verschonen
wollen als die deutschen ja das hat ja
es ist zumindest dass seine daten
und das zeigt wir können auch nicht so
ohne weiteres ein gesetz formulieren und
das wird sehr spannend chatten warum
weil in den nächsten jahren wir
natürlich maschinen haben werden die in
unserem alltag eingreifen
aber welche kultur haben die maschinen
nehmen wir mal pflegeroboter ja wenn ein
pflegeroboter aus japan kommt die
japanische kultur ist eine die weniger
ich sag mal physisch ist er fasst man
sich nicht so an wie die hier vielleicht
in der schweiz oder in deutschland der
pflegeroboter hätte also wenn man so
will eine japanische kultur und würde
konfrontiert werden mit einer alternden
schweizerin ja was völlig anderes ist
als vielleicht ein pflegeroboter aus der
schweiz der plötzlich in japan eine
ältere dame behandelt und sie vielleicht
zu viel an fast also selbst auf ganz
feinen dingen merken wir da ist
unglaublich viel neuland
aber das heißt doch wenn sitzigen wie so
ein qualitätssiegel bräuchte ja so ein
kritisches thema man irgendwie den
algorithmus erst mal testet ob gegen die
russiche imprägnierung hatte oder sowas
welche moral hatte das geht gar nicht
wenn ich sie richtig doch der global
gesehen global gesehen ist es zumindest
noch komplizierter es ist auch so
kompliziert genug warum weil wir ja im
kern testen müssen ob ein system in
einer unglaublichen vielzahl von
situationen korrekt reagiert und das ist
nicht so einfach also bei einfachen
mustern geht das aber sobald die
komplexitätsgrad zu groß ist wird es
schwierig zudem ist es so dass wenn wir
das autonome fahren nehmen viele denken
aber das kommt morgen nein es wird nicht
kommen und der grund dafür ist dass wir
uns eigentlich über die die überlegungen
des autonomen fahrens bewusst werden so
langsam wie
komplex autofahren ist warum weil
autofahren ein extrem feinsinniger
kommunikationsprozess ist ich fahre an
eine kreuzung da steht eine person nur
aufgrund des blicks weise als fahrer der
bleibt stehen oder geht über die straße
das schafft die maschine nicht
das heißt sie ist überfordert von genau
dem was uns menschen ausmacht nämlich
ein erfassen der umwelt ein feines
kommunizieren zwischen menschen was oft
gar nicht so explizit sondern er
implizit funktionieren das ist nicht
eine frage der zeit bis sie das können
sondern es sind bringt sie faires
problem ich glaube sogar darin liegt
tatsächlich kategorisch die grenze also
es gibt viele die behaupten und sagen
man könnte ein isomorph ismus nennt man
das in der mathematik also eine eins zu
eins abbildung der realität in die
digitale welt banken und ich brauche
bestimmt nicht wir sind sehr
eingeschränkt die maschinen können nur
bestimmte dinge messen ja also es gibt
nicht sensoren für eine breite ja es
gibt ein paar sachen die wir erfassen
können bewegung ja gesichtsausdruck aber
es gibt so viele feine signale etwas was
sozusagen für uns menschen da ist was
sich nicht transportieren lässt und wenn
wir irgendwann behaupten das wäre so
dass das alles geht negieren wir genau
das was uns menschen auszeichnet das ist
so ähnlich wie in der musik vor einigen
jahren die debatte war ist eine cd
genauso wie ein konzert wenn einer da
sitzung selber spielt ja nein natürlich
nicht und die cd ist nur ein kleiner
ausschnitt aus einem gesamterlebnis was
mit ihr war sogar einzigartig ist wenn
man wirklich in einem echten konzert
sitzt wenn man eine person wahrnimmt mit
einem sohn dran und im moment laufen wir
die gefahr dass wir ständig im grunde
genommen die illusion verkauft bekommen
dass eine reduzierte wirklichkeit eher
auf wenige zahlen auf messbare kriterien
auf irgendetwas was er die
vital vermittelbar ist dass das real
sein und das ist nicht der fall
was wäre dieses dieses menschliche dass
sie gesagt haben dass die maschine
ich glaube es gibt darum eine maschine
wie alexa ja dieser dieser kasten redet
von wetter und weiß nicht was es ist
alex hat keine ahnung wie sich regen im
mai auf der nase anfühlt aber das haben
sie das haben wir das heißt dieses tiefe
innere sinnliche verweben ist etwas was
wir menschen haben dass der erste punkte
zweite punkt ist wir laufen ein bisschen
gefahren dass wir den menschen der eine
unteilbare ganzheit darstellt aufteilen
in messbare objekte der mensch wird
reduziert auf ein objekt von vielen
zahlen und das ist absurd das ist so als
würde ich sagen ja
wenn ich hingehe und ich fange an dem
kopf durch den anderen zu ersetzen und
die hand durch einen anderen zu ersetzen
das kann ich in der digitalen welt
machen das machen wir heute schon also
sogar band beim gesicht ja wird ständig
gepimpt auf allen profilfotos aber die
gefahr ist dass wir das übernehmen statt
irgendwann zu sagen nein der ist so und
weil er ja so ist ist er auch nicht
veränderbar und ist dieses verwobene
ganzheitliche und das phänomenale
bewusstsein das heißt dieses erleben
dass maschinen nicht haben können sie
haben das ganz am anfang schon gesagt
die tun so als ob gelangen aber mehr ist
da nicht
jetzt möchte ich ihnen mit ihnen noch
ein bisschen auf diese
gesellschaftlichen fragen kommen sie
haben schon unterschiedliche kulturen
erwähnt japan china und so und in china
wird ja derzeit experimentiert und nicht
mehr lange dann kommt flächendeckend
einsatz aber auch kreditsystem
überwachung flächendeckend uns da und
ich glaube dass wenn man sich ja ich
glaube es kommt dass auch ja ich glaube
dass total wichtig weil wir machen es
ist zu einfach wenn wir einfach sein
dort die bösen chinesen die machen
ein social rettet das social scoring
system das sind die bösen und wir sind
gut nein also bei rot über die straße
gehen in china und dann wird man
irgendwie funktioniert also die
punktezahlen der aber was passiert bei
uns was hier eigentlich erleben sie in
zwei sachen wir erleben zunehmend ich
drücke das mal ganz hart aus eine
diktatur der transparenz eine diktatur
der bewertung wenn sie im internet
einkaufen hier in der schweiz
dann sind sie sterne ja einmal zweimal
dreimal vier die den verkäufer beziffern
ja wir fangen heute schon an und haben
apps und da steht drauf wie war die
aktivität heute wir haben in ganz vielen
anderen bereichen
ein denken bei dem des core also im
grunde genommen die punkte zahl immer
wieder assoziiert wird zu ihrem
verhalten und damit rutschen wir
automatisch genau in das denken was in
china auch da ist nämlich gefangen an
lebensprozesse nur noch numerisch zu
bewerten und irgendwann zu sagen der hat
fünf sterne und die ansätze fangen
irgendwann bei versicherungen ja weil
das sind die hintertüren ja wenn sie mir
ihre bewegungsdaten geben kriegen sie
von der versicherung ein rabatt
das wird passieren natürlich die leute
wollen geld sparen und implizit fangen
wir an die normativen kräfte ja die da
essentiell sind nämlich ich muss mich
bewegen sonst zahle ich mehr und damit
endet die freiheit und es wird zu einem
zwang
wir richten unser verhalten aus es wird
gesteuert subtil vielleicht ein anfang
wir werden permanent bewertet wenn ich
sie richtig verstehe nicht nur in china
sondern auch hier nicht durch den staat
sondern durch andre und die kühe
auf diese bewertung gehen wir merken
nicht dass zum beispiel in den
informationsflüssen in sozialen
netzwerken ja bewertung sprich was für
ein artikel wird häufig angeklickt der
wird per algorithmus nach oben gesorgt
heißt wer zur hölle werken dass wir
selbst verstärkung mechanismen haben die
am ende dann ja dazu führen dass sogar
falsche nachrichten sich plötzlich
dramatisch schneller ausbreiten das
heißt wir rutschen in ein denken rein
was nicht so sehr aus china stammt
sondern was damit einhergeht dass wir
irgendwann das verhältnis zwischen uns
und der maschine klar haben müssen und
ich sage ganz offen ich möchte in einem
land leben bei denen ich bei rot über
die ampel gehen darf ich mein ich habe
indische wurzeln mein vater ist in der
der sagte mir immer die bei grün aber
schauer auch bei rot ja das ist eine
andere form wie man an ein leben angeht
und in dem moment wo wir aus diesen
option total kontrolle machen beenden
wir die moralische fähigkeit des
menschen
dann können sie nicht mehr handeln und
man sollte sich das recht behalten um
vernünftig zu sein und da was anderes zu
tun
jetzt der unterschied aus leicht zu
china das bei uns nicht der staat die
die macht hat und die daten sondern
große internet konzern google facebook
und da ballt sich die macht was ich da
die daten bauen jetzt ist die frage was
wir aus bürgerinnen und bürger und was
die politik
europa dagegen tun kann ja ich bin sehr
klar und werfe ein bisschen der politik
vor dass sie zusammen ist weil wir eine
machtkonzentration dieser daten mit all
den daraus resultierenden konsequenzen
weil je geht es nicht nur darum einfach
zu wissen was
ist yves bost morgens zum frühstück oder
niveau bewegt er sich hin sondern diese
daten paaren mit informationen führt
dazu dass ich immer sein kann was muss
ich oft besser als input geben damit er
sich so verhält und ich kann anfangen
menschen zu beeinflussen
und ich finde einfach an der stelle ist
es ein gebot dass wir ein gerechter
daten brauchen wir müssen an irgend
einer stelle die größe diese kohäsion
der daten die vereint ist bei wenigen
firmen die müssen wir auf sparten
wasserball konkret das heißt ganz
konkret google google facebook amazon
zerschlagen zerschlagen heißt dann der
stelle wirklich diese monopolistischen
strukturen aufgeben es kann nicht sein
nehmen wir google dass ein unternehmen
weiß was ich suche weiß wo ich bin
google maps weiß was ich abends gucke
wenn ich youtube gucke weiß was ich wenn
google chrome installiert ist zuhause
heede usw also diese art von kombination
der daten ist brandgefährlich
nicht weil google jetzt böse leute hat
sondern weil sie im grunde genommen der
nährboden sind für autoritäre systeme
wenn wir uns einfach einen moment lang
vorstellen warum sind die den nährboden
für ein drittes weil weil in den
bereichen geld machen nein autoritären
die sie bereiten den nährboden für
autoritäre systeme vor und die paarung
ist an irgendeiner stelle mit geld nicht
ganz so trivial plattform sind
inzwischen die wertvollsten unternehmen
der welt
also in den letzten 20 jahren haben sich
die karten neu gemischt
und was passiert wenn irgendwann diese
total kontrolle ihnen ermöglicht in
politik in entscheidungskriterium einer
einer gesellschaft hinein zu gehen
möglicherweise wettbewerber massiv zu
verbringen ich meine die größten strafen
der eu wurden verhängt an genau diese
großen firmen und ich sage noch einmal
dass sie nie missverstanden werde ich
kenne ich habe freunde bei google er an
der gips total nette kollegen aber
dieses konstrukt ist durch seine größe
an irgendeiner stelle für uns als
gesellschaft nicht akzeptabel und wir
brauchen alternativ das heißt ein
europäisches kuchen oder ein
europäisches facebook sowie china das
hat er eigene netzwerke all jene gene
eigene netzwerke eine klare regelung
welche daten so zu sagen in welcher
kombination für welchen zweck verwendet
werden dürfen
eine offenlegung der algorithmen wenn es
bei sozialen netzwerken und wir wissen
dass nur spätestens seit letztem jahr
das soziale netzwerke durchaus das
potenzial haben wahlen zu beeinflussen
also demokratie zu destabilisieren nun
wenn etwas so groß ist dann finde ich
gibt es irgendwann eine neue qualität
und die bedingt aus meiner sicht so
etwas wie eine demokratische
offenlegungspflicht also ich meine was
tatsächlich facebook macht ist immer
noch bei einer blackbox und es geht
nicht weil sie zu wichtig sind und wir
haben ja inzwischen gelernt dass sie
wichtig sind im bezug auf politische
entscheidungen in bezug auf ein
erstarken zb von extremen positionen die
am ende zu politischen entscheidungen
führen
nehmen wir den break sit ja fragte sich
einen moment und der bretone sozialen
netzwerke überhaupt gekommen wäre und
das wird dazu dass wir in gesellschaften
hineinrutschen die plötzlich instabil
werden ja und das hat ganz viele andere
konsequenzen also ich glaube da ist es
ein gebot bei aller freude am
fortschritt also ich will da nicht jetzt
missverstanden werden dass die sagen er
will kein fortschritt nein aber dass sie
einfach klar sind und diese
monopolistischen strukturen dürfen wir
nicht zulassen
und da muss die politik wirklich handeln
sie tut es nicht die sagen ja einerseits
braucht mehr regulierung
es braucht aber auch mehr forschung
sonst sind wir irgendwann im
hintertreffen gegenüber einer klaren usa
und so weiter ich möchte mit ihnen jetzt
gegen ende der sendung noch ein bisschen
in die zukunft gucken und fragen was wir
eigentlich mit unseren kleinen machen
sollen mit unseren kindern welche art
von schulstoff die haben sorgen wenn
diese maschinen das meiste eigentlich
uns abnehmen können
arbeit an denken und so weiter also was
muss in der bildung passieren also es
gibt mehr sachen und in die zukunft zu
gucken immer total schwer
man könnte sogar eine extreme position
einnehmen und sagen was könnte passieren
wenn maschinen irgendwann in der lage
sind gesprochene worte zu verstehen
werden wir möglicherweise schritt für
schritt in eine post text gesellschaft
rutschen bei denen ich mir gelesen wird
weil die maschine vorliest wir erleben
dass heute schon wir leben das dadurch
dass wenn menschen eine
betriebsanleitung die lesen sie nicht
mehr durch tagungen sich in dem
youtube-video an
wir sehen es daran dass bücher nehmen
sie den deutschen buchmarkt er hat in
vier jahren das waren die zahlen der
letzten buchmesse 6 millionen leser
verloren
das heißt wir rutschen in eine
gesellschaft rhein bei der das
gesprochene und geschriebene wort für
einen großen teil der menschen anfängt
immer unbedeutender zu werden
was bedeutet das jetzt für die
ausbildung also wenn ich demnächst
messages diktiere muss ich dann noch
schöne schreibschrift ja ebenso wie ich
das in der schule gemacht habe wenn
apparate mittlerweise in zukunft flüssig
übersetzen muss ich dann noch die
fremdsprache lernen aber es ist doch
noch viel radikaler man kann sagen alle
repetitiven tätigkeiten können
wahrscheinlich irgendwann mal bald
thematisiert das heißt was bleibt uns
kreativität vielleicht aber jetzt die
junge arbeit aber ihre frage was machen
wir mit den kleinen also ich habe nur
mal die tür aufgemacht und prinzipiell
gesagt das könnte man alles überlegen
auf der anderen seite ich sie vielleicht
weniger aber ich bin definitiv sozusagen
analog aufgewachsen und ich glaube das
ist das was essentiell ist für junge
menschen
wir sind organisch wir brauchen das
haptische ich meine wenn sie kleine
kinder haben merken sie ja die probieren
alles die stecken die würden die kleinen
würfel von cosmo der vorher da waren ja
das heißt lernen ist ein hochkomplexer
sinnlicher extrem emotional euro sicher
von körperlicher prozess der mit ganz
viel einhergeht bis heute versteht man
das nicht im detail und zu meinen wir
könnten das jetzt irgendwann durch
bildschirm oder durch die platte welt ja
das digital abbilden ist ein grober
fehler
wir brauchen eine technische kompetenz
ja wir brauchen einen medienkompetenz
auf dauer jahr wir müssen wissen wie
geht man damit um
sie haben kleine kinder viel spaß wenn
die ein bisschen älter werden wird der
streit anfangen irak sie sagen nachher
was sie mehr tipps wie alle anderen
kinder haben ein handy nur ich habe
keinen alle anderen kinder dürfen aber
viel länger ja im internet spielen und
so weiter das sind zuerst einmal
konflikte die erzeugt werden weil
natürlich rein ökonomisch er im grunde
genommen hier eine junge zielgruppe
bereits angefeuert wird aber der
entscheidende punkt ist wir müssen
lernen zu reflektieren und zu gestalten
das bedeutet wir wollen nicht eine
gesellschaft haben bei der kinder
konsumenten werden eine technik sondern
ich wünsche mir eine gesellschaft bei
der kinder gestalten und das bedeutet
sie müssen die fähigkeit haben selber zu
programmieren selber zu verstehen wie
das geht selber zu bauen und sie müssen
dann eben glaube ich nicht vergessen
oder dürfen nicht vergessen dass es eine
realität gibt das holz echtes holz oder
dass man klopft nicht muss ich irgendwie
anhört sondern er ist schwingt es hat
was anderes das kriegen sie nicht
ersetzt durch ein mausklick auf einer
holzplatte im digitalen universum das
geht nicht
und was machen wir mit allen erwachsenen
die die jobs verlieren werden es gibt
sehr unterschiedliche prognosen die
einen sagen 50 der jobs werden wegfallen
in den nächsten 20 jahren die anderen
sagen es kommen neue jobs dazu müssen
wir unser sozialsystem grundlegend
umdenken richard david precht der
deutsche philosoph er hat sogar ein
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen schon
darüber diskutiert ja ich glaube
folgendes wir müssen schritt für schritt
gehen ich mein ich bin ja in der schweiz
und da werden menschen mich verstehen
bergsteiger die sterben meistens nicht
auf dem gipfel
sie sterben auf dem weg dahin wir sind
auf dem weg in eine digitale welt und
die etappen dazwischen bringen schon so
viel die stabilisierung dass wir damit
fertig werden müssen das heißt die zeit
wo 50 prozent der jobs verschwinden die
ist noch weit weg aber auf dem weg dahin
merken wir jetzt zum beispiel dass
medien schon anfang ja demokratien zu
destabilisieren und wenn demokrat
demokratien installieren werden hat das
konsequenzen auf jobs ich meine schauen
sie sich mal an was im moment sozusagen
der weltpolitik los ist durch
interventionismus durch zoll
beschränkungen durch handelskriege ja
die alle angefeuert wurden eigentlich
eher durch sehr viel feuer aus und in
den sozialen netzwerken und die führen
am ende dazu dass wahrscheinlich mehr
jobs dadurch verloren gehen als durch
ein apparat der irgendeine stumpfsinnige
arbeit eines menschen ersetzt herr
yogeshwar man spürt sie haben viel
faszination für für die welt die denken
sich tief greifenden ganz
unterschiedliche themen nein sind sie
ein neugieriger mensch haben physik
studiert er hatte irgendwie über das
ganz kleine geforscht elementarteilchen
bis zur kosmologie oder astrophysik bei
ihnen im garten steht glaube ich eine
sternwarte habe ja gelesen aber das
wetter ist leider oft viel viel viel zu
schlecht aber wenn sie darin die sterne
k
da stellt man sich ja die großen fragen
was ist nur für sie das größte er jetzt
auf dieser wert auch das größte rätsel
wenn sie wenn sie kinder haben und ein
kind geboren wird das wenn sie demnächst
mal wieder erleben das ist für mich
somit das größte berührendste wärmste
rätsel was es gibt also die tatsache
dass ein lebewesen in dieser perfektion
in dieser filigranität und so weiter an
entsteht ist wow
natürlich gibt es noch andere große
fragen aber ich glaube das ist die
sozusagen die jeder von uns unter seiner
haut trägt und die auch wenn diese
kinder groß werden eigentlich klar macht
hey das leben ist unglaublich spannend
und das glaube ich ist um noch mal auf
das thema könnte intelligenz
zurückzukommen das ist nicht abbildbar
also die komplexität wie sind sie jetzt
wird's irgendwann früher auch in den
bergen
wenn sie auf einer alm gehen und sich
diese vielfalt angucken die kriegen sie
nicht die tage produziert und sie können
genau hingucken und das ist eine magie
wo auf die wissenschaft keine erklärung
hat worauf auch wir als menschen keine
erklärung haben
aber wir haben einen lebensraum und das
ist vielleicht das implizite verstehen
und nicht das explizite formeln
aufschreiben und sagen warum das so ist
also wir leben entsteht sie haben das
viele erlebt sie hatten vier eigene
kinder ja man kann auch an das ende des
lebens gehen fragen nach dem tod
und da gibt es auch im silicon valley
jetzt vordenkern gibt utopien
ja leute die das leben heraus zögern
jetzt 130 55 vielleicht sogar
unsterblich oder leben auf dem mond sehr
hat die utopien sprießt das leben ist
glaube ich eine wichtige utopie um das
silicon valley zu verstehen warum
stellen sie sich vor sie hätten
milliarden
sie können sich alles kaufen jede yacht
jedes flugzeug was ich nicht kaufen
können ist dass sie momentan auf jeden
fall endlich leben
das ist die große tür durch die alle
müssen ja die millionäre genauso wie die
armen schlucker
und genau da versucht man natürlich
jetzt wenn sie viel geld haben zu sagen
können wir diese tür schieben
aber das ist eine hybris der seine
hybris weilen dahinter natürlich eine
vision ist was passiert wenn ein mensch
richtig alt wird er wie notwendig ist
das wollen sie unsterblich sein
ich persönlich nicht ich glaube es
langweilig aber die idee dahinter ist
irgendwie oder das bedürfnis die
sehnsucht ist doch das menschsein selbst
zu überwinden so etwas vielleicht zu
einer maschine zu werden dem sei das
menschsein beinhaltet das bewusstsein
unserer vergänglichkeit wenn wir dieses
bewusstsein nicht hätten wären wir nicht
menschen das gehört dazu dieses memento
mori schwingt in unseren zellen
wir erleben es durch das ständige
verlieren auch er von menschen in
unserem umfeld ja die die großmutter die
eltern irgendwann wenn sie gehen die
freunde das gehört dazu dieses fast
schon absurde dass wir beide hier an
einem tisch sitzen und in 100 jahren
vielleicht der tisch noch irgendwo
hoffentlich recycelt wurde aber wir
nicht mehr da sind
hält man als mensch kaum aus aber das
gehört dazu und es gibt ein
trostpflaster ob dass religion sind ja
die in gewisser weise einem die hoffnung
geben dass es danach weiter gibt oder
man ist so wie ich er atheist und sagt
okay das war's das gehört dazu herr
yogeshwar vielen herzlichen dank für
dieses
brechen danke auch ja und danke ich
ihnen für das mitdenken nächste woche
sitzen hier am tisch vier frauen barbara
beuys spricht anlässlich des frauen
streiks vom nächsten freitag mit drei
jungen philosophen über die philosophie
hinter dem feminismus und jetzt gleich
zeigen wir den film die unbeugsamen drei
fragen die dafür kämpfen dass 1919 also
vor 100 jahren das frauenwahlrecht in
deutschland und österreich eingeführt
wurde in der schweiz dauert das
bekanntlich ein bisschen länger bleiben
sie also dran und einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]